[Applaudissements]
j'avais une prof de français mais qui
était qui était que j'adorerais que
j'aime bofa qui est qui est toujours
vivante d'ailleurs s'appeler comment
madame manin c'était ma prof de français
et de latin et de grec at you play voilà
je te muriel peut nous dire parce que
muriel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cyril féraud quand on pense à cyril
féraud si c'est cyril féraud et bien
vous participerez haslam ils feront
ainsi un record absolu
mais bon voilà c'est vrai j'ai le tee
shirt de l'époque ronald à je vais
ramener mon chéri le vrai
mais je te jure confiance et gérard
jugnot et ses amis et c'est pour la
promo du film même s'il faut un peu tard
mais le brillant film sur le prochain
film pour une association a banalisé
je connais l'alphabet grec parker à
dizzy alfa beta gamma delta epsilon
l'état est apte et taille haute à capa
lambda minuk si omicron pire au sigma
tau upsilon philippe scy aux médias
[Applaudissements]